it looks like my English teacher well
last one King under sting Ellison
beautiful tip breasts then watermelons a
shake I love it already
Florida due to the coronavirus off Tommy
is a hairdresser I'm a cast member at
Walt Disney World and so we've been
googling like different ways to make
money at home and one of the ways we
found was to sell your panties online
and we thought it might be a great idea
maybe name our store the cookie jar who
knows no call it sweet dude call it
business streaks and you guys just sell
undies Rodriquez a very uni I think
you're limiting your audience there's
some women there's people that just want
a warm piece of panties in the mail yeah
it's not a bad idea I think they should
call start a business called streaks and
then start fans only calm also I can't
believe [ __ ] khloe kardashian I can
do the Teager sting look I think yeah
the late this is obviously the lady from
frozen fro and uh you could easily sell
your panties to somebody you know I
think you could even just start local do
Craig's lesser you know if you don't
want to open up the full Shopify I also
think you can [ __ ] so pictures them
text she's trying to do a legal business
you free you can do that legally sell
panties called streaks and [ __ ] oil
up them tits and sell it dude there's a
huge business out there that's that dark
web then dark Hush Puppies get them out
make some money girl I mean I have to
look if you feel like going to that
extent I think you'll learn by starting
off with just the panties they may be
seeing what other things you could put
in the car and I stand by streets I
stand by streaks call it streaks man
yeah yeah stand by that
what do you think Chappell you gonna
throw some bread on the internet for
some tits or for some pain have you ever
done anything like that I've ever bought
under women's underwear anything
coughing uh no I've never done anything
like that I've sniffed some underwear
okay really I'm not into there that's
normal oh hey chin in Asia catch isn't
there vending machines with Annies yeah
I do
well I don't know if they're streets
there but there's use panties and yeah
Betty Jean yeah you know did you know
that like you know we can get [ __ ]
Kit Kats and [ __ ] pretzels you can
get streak undies in Japan mmm I like it
I wouldn't mind if you're having a tough
day or something you pull over grab a
cup grab a parent us huh fun while
you're driving along the interstate yeah
and you wonder where they got Corona you
know I'm saying dude can't be smell
smelling [ __ ] undies all day yeah
you're right
all smells fresh sneakers though yep
them sneakers say I get high off those
right now yeah yeah look at that dude
get you a pair of undies out of that
with a vending machine
get your little panty bra and some
people wear a panty on their head till
you see it sometime burger now there's
another thing you could do sell burglar
attire that's true quit Bergling in that
same old [ __ ] you know saying get out
there and these be in these scented
hitters that robbers do dude yeah okay
rods ahead of the time
oh you right you were some hey hos all
the time blows shoot his cousin in the
chest
good luck girl or is he man we gotta
interview him can we do can we think we
can do a Skype with him next week
absolutely he di means the other day cuz
he was gonna come by Toronto show and he
said I think I got cancelled brother
yeah I can well there's a beautiful
young lady and I think you look you
could probably sell 40 pairs as two
people to watch this show so I think you
guys should do it good luck girl and
what's a good price you think cat if
somebody's gonna sell like their panties
and I'm not asking because I would think
you know I'm just saying you're the only
female in here if you legit we're gonna
suggest to this lady a price what do you
think I think it depends on each person
like
it really depends on who's willing if
someone's want to buy it for $50 or $100
that's just market value
I think $19.99 sounds pretty fair in
this one I don't want to double whatever
you pay for the pants crazy Brendon well
I don't know how much your panties I
don't know at least depends on where you
get them just give me like a norm like a
twenty thirty secret Victoria's Secret
they have a 5 for 28 deal 5 for 28 and I
sell each pair for $19.99 mm-hmm okay
but I think I $20 if I'm gonna get I
feel like if I'm paying for something
like that I'm willing to pay $40 I'm
willing to pay fifty dollars I don't
want that $20 pairs you want that $20
Street killer also if you don't realize
this shipping involved - mm $4.99 for
shipping I see no yeah $100 deep you
really okay see it all the yellow in
your market no do they bottle it him
first
that's a good point you get a picture
with the minim now if you throw in that
photograph I think you're talking an
extra 10 $15 now you're taught you got
that combo pack where you wear it and
you got your tits out oiled up yeah I'll
pay a nice $49.99 also don't limit
yourself use your socks - yeah people
like some people like feet and some of
the scent is gonna go away in the mail
that's the problem with the mail you
lose half the sent in the mail now if
you spray a little of that perfume on
vacuum-seal yeah I think if you vacuum
seal them now you're talking so now I
think you can get up into the $80 range
back you see you more overhead - so you
gotta go higher but but see now you know
you make you make a trip to the post
office in a day you drop off for payers
you're clearing fifty dollars a pair
after all your expenses streaks are us
200 but I made worse name though I'm
gonna vote knowing streaks are on what
would be a good name email and I'm just
saying bad name I'm not saying you're a
bad guys you know like streaks I don't
like I'm not buying something from
streaks are us Underpants women
super soakers is very interesting that
names taken by the water gun yeah maybe
[Laughter]
that's a good one a good one
yeah what would be a good name streaks
crab two scoops I like from the hole
yeah I just like it different I like
that maybe scoops panty Emporium oops
yeah scoop it up dog scoop it up or the
panty shanty what about that panty shot
yeah panty panty shot what else man
panty panty time hey anytime there you
go
and it's an it's an o'clock and it just
shows panties on the top no watches now
- no expense no watches black pant ether
[Laughter]
which have a different darker paint and
we're gonna play on Victoria's Secret mm
okay Oh Victoria Peak written is a
little bit of urine and what's the gross
no I like that I don't like it let's
discuss I still like streaks I really
think it's gonna catch on
shrieks streaks are unexpected streets
to me sounds like dirty underwear
that's how cute that's what you mean
yeah this I mean maybe they do I've
never done it I've never bought it
you're right what do you guys think
nikkor chain you guys seem like somebody
over maybe invest in something panting
mo diem or like how do you say
pandemonium panty mo diem pants imodium
yeah yeah imodium is a diarrhea drug yes
about pay that Pipers penny pipers
painting diapers I like that Paul's
panty pipers
yeah like that Paul's panty tech pay oh
that's her name it's gonna help me
charge for crimson Allyson Nelson's
panty Emporium that's how we got today -
Allison's Allison's ant eaters Allison's
she and a friend who was doing it - what
was your Florida I have a little for you
so me and my friend were both recently
just laid off okay they laid off so um
she played a Disney character oh yes she
was a Disney character Don I wish she
told us which one I bet it's got to be
frozen huh
I don't know why you keep thinking she's
[ __ ] frozen dude there's only thing
she's a plane there's two women in from
hey there's two women in frozen right
and who are the women in frozen Elsa and
Elsa yeah she could easily be one of
those women have you seen the cartoon
yeah okay maybe froze Oh thawed out Bob
out thoughts yeah thought out thought
where yeah thought where yeah car
thoughts
what about thoughts are us ooh now we're
talking what if you did panties from
different female characters Cinderella's
panties Beauty and the Beast you pay a
nice little pansy
yeah pieces covered and [ __ ] it's the
Beast unveiling [ __ ] across the mail you
can't do that well I need a few other
facts I'm sinking in China Asia that's
what yeah you smell a panty Brian nobody
wants duty in the pan okay soso duties
out those details before we started this
brainstorm they want a scent of a woman
they don't like a sick woman you know is
it duty-free Goods dude
FedEx and turds
he wasn't catching our hints the whole
time
no street sweet sorrows now Oh Brendan
well these are details I needed before
we start this whole brainstorming
operation yeah maybe we're yeah I think
duty-free maybe duty-free and some of at
the airport you're limiting your [ __ ]
demo there man some guy's gonna kill you
once a surprise we can have shell
companies we have duty-free and Duty
full I need to know what Disney
character she plays to be decided how
about this let's do all I have people
submit for next week just some names of
good names for companies for a female
that wants to sell Underpants and also
follow up well let's see what Disney
character she is that's gonna help us
[Music]